[Music]
before we start this video I noticed
that only 15% of you are subscribed so
if you enjoy the content please hit the
subscribe button
heyy everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video we're going to be discussing
the history of the three unforgivable
curses we will be touching on whether
came from what they are why they are
considered to be unforgivable and
whether or not you're able to cast them
non-verbally let's kick things off with
a quote from Alastor Moody actually
Barty Crouch jr. in chapter 14 of the
Goblet of Fire now those three curses
Avada Kedavra imperious and cruci
artists are known as the unforgivable
curses the use of any one of them on a
fellow human being is enough to earn a
life sentence in Azkaban that's what
you're up against that's what I've got
to teach you to fight you need preparing
you need arming but most of all you need
to practice constant never ceasing
vigilance get out your quills copy this
down the first thing that you need to
know is that the unforgivable curses are
three of the most powerful and sinister
spells known to the Wizarding World they
are tools of the dark arts and generally
only used by the darkest and most
sadistic witches and wizards let's start
by taking a look at each of the three
unforgivable curses number one the
Imperius curse the first unforgivable
curse in this list is the Imperius curse
or Imperia Imperial comes from the Latin
Imperial which means I command Imperial
is most often used by dark witches and
wizards and when it is cast on a victim
they are forced to perform the
unquestioned bidding of the caster being
under the control of this spell is said
to be like experiencing a wonderful
release from any sense of responsibility
making the victim extremely susceptible
to any sort of influence from the caster
because of this adopted carefree
attitude the victim is inclined to carry
out tasks for the caster without any
sort of moral compass or awareness of
the casters intentions or desires while
under the imperious
Herry experienced the following it was
the most wonderful feeling Harry felt a
floating sensation as every thought and
worry in his head was wiped gently away
leaving nothing but a vague untraceable
happiness he stood there feeling
immensely relaxed only dimly aware of
everyone watching him number 2 the
Cruciatus curse the second unforgivable
curse in the list is the Cruciatus curse
otherwise known as crucio
crucio literally translates to I torture
in Latin so you can already begin to get
an idea of what this spell does crucio
is most often used by dark witches and
wizards and a known proponent of crucio
is Bellatrix Lestrange he used it to
torture Alice and Frank Longbottom when
cast
crucio inflicts excruciating pain on the
victim pains so excruciating that it is
considered to be torturous casting
crucio is said to require a wand and
incantation and its effects are said to
vary depending on the casters desires
and emotions to produce the excruciating
pain implied by the name the caster must
despise the victim and enjoy causing
pain Harry Potter
after crucio was cast on him described
it as feeling like his head was being
split open while having his bones set on
fire number 3 Avada Kedavra the third
and most life-threatening curse on the
list is of course the killing curse
otherwise known as Avada Kedavra
Avada Kedavra 'he's purpose is simple it
causes the victim to instantly die if
you want to kill your victim then this
is the spell to use Lord Voldemort is a
proponent of the spell which creates a
blindingly intense green bolt of light
right before the victim simply drops
dead there are two theories for how they
die the first claiming that the victims
internal organs cease to function after
being struck and the second claiming
that the soul of the victim is magically
ripped from their body the three cursors
are called
unforgivable because of their sadistic
nature the spells were deemed too
powerful and sadistic to be freely used
in the Wizarding World and that is why
they warrant a life sentence to ask
the capacity to torture people control
them against their will and kill them
with a single incantation is not
something that could be left
unrecognized or unpunished in society
using any of the three unforgivable
curses on another human being
muggle or wizard would get you sent
straight to Azkaban the only way of
getting out of this is if you are able
to prove that you were under the control
of the Imperius curse the reason for
these three curses being unforgivable is
simple legislation they were first
classified as unforgivable and illegal
by the Ministry of Magic in the Year
1717 at the same time the strictest
penalties were put in place and attached
to their use before 1717 we can only
assume that they were regarded just like
any of the spell and while we don't have
any information to support this there
must have been some sort of catalyst
that made the ministry truly realize how
dangerous these spells were yulik camp
was the Minister for magic at the time
the spells were outlawed with just one
year left in his term perhaps something
happened involving these spells that
threatened his position I can only
imagine the chaos that something like
the Imperius curse would cause in a
government structure like that perhaps a
concerned camp had just outlawed them to
further secure his position the three
spells were truly set apart from others
and they were very clearly categorized
and outlawed what's interesting however
is that while these three spells are
pretty awful and the potential for
destruction is high there are other
spells that exist in the Wizarding World
that have the same potential for damage
why is Sectumsempra not an unforgivable
curse perhaps it's just too obscure why
isn't the highly destructive fiend fire
an unforgivable curse perhaps is just
too hard to cast why is it okay to
completely wipe someone's memories with
something like obliviate and why is it
okay to transform someone into an animal
against their will it seems like there
should be legislation that addresses
these sorts of spells as well it's
really unclear as to why these three
spells have been isolated is it just
that the unforgivable curses are too
inherently
evil this is where things get a bit
tricky just because the three
unforgivable curses bear the potential
to be destructive it doesn't necessarily
mean that they are inherently evil I can
think of some use cases for two out of
three of the unforgivable curses that
contradict the evil label that they've
been given
first there's Imperia which Herod uses
on the Goblin at Gringotts in order to
penetrate the Lestrange vault harry
didn't manipulate the goblin to any
significant extent or hold control over
him for any considerable amount of time
he just got what he needed and released
the curse I would argue that this wasn't
an evil use of the curse just a
necessary one next there's Avada Kedavra
Snape uses Avada Kedavra on Dumbledore
to end his life but it was not a
malicious murder attempt it was a
preordained outcome that was discussed
by all parties Snape's use of Avada
Kedavra on Dumbledore was firstly an act
of mercy as it ended his suffering and
secondly it was a necessary act that
Snape had to perform in order to remain
a trusted Death Eater had Snape not
retained Baltimore's loyalty at this
time then the whole outcome of the books
and films could have been completely
different
perhaps favoring the bad guys as for
crucio it's a little bit harder to make
an argument for it not being inherently
evil the whole point of crucio is to
torture someone which no matter what the
situation is is probably never a good
thing to do there are a few other
theories as to why these spells are
deemed unforgiveable outside of the fact
that they are outlawed there is
speculation that the unforgivable tag
alludes to the concept of unforgivable
sin which exists in some faiths an
unforgivable sin is an act that makes
salvation impossible this would make
sense with regards to the respective
spells effects particularly the killing
curse and Cruciatus curse we see many
characters perform the unforgivable
curses in the books and films and
usually when they were mentioned we are
the read or heard the incantation being
uttered from Acosta's mouth
Voldemort seems to love saying Avada
Kedavra which made me wonder is it
necessary
though the books and films make it seem
like yelling the incantation is always
necessary that actually isn't the case
as there are several instances in which
Avada Kedavra and other spells are cast
without any sort of incantation in the
ministry atrium duel Voldemort seems to
switch back and forth between saying it
and not saying it which is unusual
example the first time he uses it I have
nothing more to say to you Potter he
said quietly
you have act me too often for too long
Avada Kedavra and the second time he
uses it Voldemort raised his wand and
another jet of green light streaked at
Dumbledore who turned and was gone in a
whirling of his cloak so if it's not
necessary to sight the incantation I
wonder why it's ever uttered at all in
the books
Hermione discusses the advantage of
nonverbal magic your adversary has no
warning about what kind of magic you're
about to perform said Hermione which
gives you a split second advantage in
the case of Voldemort using Avada
Kedavra on Dumbledore he would want
every advantage that he could get so I
understand the rationale here however I
wonder if the power of the spell is
somehow mitigated when it's cast
non-verbally if it isn't then why switch
between saying and not saying the
incantation anyway to answer the initial
question no it's not necessary to
verbally state the incantation when
performing the unforgivable curses and
that's it for this video I hope that
gives you guys a little bit more
information on the three unforgivable
curses if you guys have any further
question on them comment them down below
until next time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]
you